supernovae have been in the news a bit
recently there was a supernova went off
in him 95 last week and in fact we made
a couple of videos for deep sky video
talking about that particular supernova
so this is the but that's led into sort
of more general questions about what a
supernova actually is and particularly
the symbols we use for defining a
supernova and this supernova that went
off last week was a type 2 supernova so
I thought I'd talk a little bit about
what a type 2 supernova actually is so
the symbol for type 2 supernova is SN 4
supernova and then - in Roman numerals
so it's not very exciting symbol I'm
afraid so it's got a two lies to me
there's a 1 there are yes it's the
classic thing that's Ron um is my doing
is that they like classifying things and
actually usually the way this works we
end up classifying things before we
understand what they are so often the
classifications have no real physical
significance to them at all the main
difference between type 1 and type 2
supernova is all the placed on the
spectra and when you analyze the spectra
of these things so you break the light
up into the colors of the rainbow
you see these characteristic absorption
bands due to the various different
chemical elements and in type 2
supernova you find these very strong
absorption lines from hydrogen and in
type 1 supernova you don't so the
classification really was that basic
observational thing of when I see an
exploding star does it have these
absorption lines from hydrogen in it or
not so the sort of fundamentally
different processes going on I mean
they're both exploding stars the type 1
supernovae mostly look like they're
probably sort of white dwarf stars that
just sort of get tipped over an edge so
they could keep a creating matter until
they get too massive and then they
collapse type 2 supernova are just stars
that have reached the end of their lives
very massive stars reach the end of
their lives you've got to have an energy
source at the center of a star to
counteract the effects of gravity
basically gravity's trying to pull
everything in words all the time and you
need something in the center to stop
that clamps of course when a star is
going through its lifetime it has these
various sources of nuclear power nuclear
fusion going on in the center but
eventually all those nuclear fuel
sources run out and when a massive star
which is that point and you no longer
got anything to provide that energy
source in the middle the center of the
star just basically collapses down so
you have what's known as a core collapse
supernova that the center of the star
collapses under gravity
well that sounds all well and good
professor but that's just something
collapsing supernovas are these
super-bright amazing explosions that's
the weird thing when it's actually the
what powers a supernova is this collapse
but of course what you actually see is
stuck getting flung out and so the
obvious question is how something
collapses can then cause an explosion
like things actually flying outwards and
actually the process the details of the
process are not that well understood
still even today in that for example
part of what drives that outward
expansion is neutrinos like these almost
massless pathetic little particles in
the universe that usually just go
streaming through everything that core
collapse actually generates huge numbers
of neutrinos so most of the energy of a
supernova explosion is actually in
neutrinos and somehow those neutrinos
then transfer their energy to the outer
layers of the star to make it explode
outwards and it's not trivial how that
happens because neutrinos typically
don't interact with things very much at
all but somehow sort of 1% of the energy
and the neutrinos has to get transferred
to that outer envelope to drive it
outwards so the fundamental question is
here is how something collapsing can
actually lead to an explosion how it is
that something falling in on itself can
actually lead to something actually
being flung out into space at high speed
and the way this works is that the bit
that gets flung out into space is quite
a small part of the star and you can
actually transfer the energy from the
collapsed collapsing large part of the
star to this small part of the star and
actually get it to fly out into space
and there's a classic demonstration for
this so I have a football and a tennis
ball I'm sure all I'm going to do is
balance one on top of the other and I'm
going to drop them and you can think of
these as two bits of the star a big bit
of the star and a little bit of the star
that are collapsing under gravity and
eventually the collapse stops and the
clap stops very suddenly when this thing
turns into a neutron star and that
sudden stop will then transfer energy to
this small part of the star and fling it
out into space okay so here we go if I
just drop the two in contact with one
another
you actually end up transferring a lot
of energy to the smaller part of the
star and it you get this
counterintuitive thing that you're used
to when you drop something the height it
comes back up to is either less than or
equal to the height that you dropped it
from but because you're transferring
energy in this way you can actually end
up with the little bit getting flung far
further than it fell from in the first
place
we the only massive stars that in their
life in this way so the type 2 supernova
typically a star's gotta be around 8
solar masses are above to go through
this process and end up exploding as a
supernova
I mean sometimes it goes really well we
will hit this evening in a second if a
star is over this threshold is
inevitable that will sleep in over I
think so I it's a very good question and
I don't know a definitive answer to it
that's possible there might be ways so
really you need to end up with a star
that has quite a lot of mass at the end
of its life if the Sun process that
makes that star lose that mass before it
gets the end of its life then it won't
explode as a supernova so any star that
sort of ends its life as a massive star
will blow up as a supernova but if
there's some process by which a star can
kind of lose weight during the course of
its life by interacting with other stars
those kinds of things then maybe it can
avoid this fate the year what type one
somebody else has to be involved right
it's not just the natural into a star's
life in that type one supernova you're
it's it's a white dwarf star as a
creating material and goes over some
magic limit now in order to do that to
go over that mass limit called the
Chandrasekar mass you have to have a
source of mass from somewhere which
almost always means as a companion star
in orbit around it which is having
material ripped off and falling onto the
onto the white dwarf star to tip it over
this age so type one supernova seemed to
be always associated with binary stars
where there's an extra source of mass to
tip the star over this edge whereas type
2 supernova can be isolated stars that
just naturally reach the end of their
lives and blown up every time we make a
video about supernovae we inevitably get
comments under the YouTube video about a
star called Betelgeuse so Betelgeuse is
a relatively nearby stars probably the
closest star to us that's in danger of
blowing up as a supernova supposedly it
I mean it's somewhere in in these final
phases of its life right and so it will
indeed blow up but the time scales
involved although they're short for a
star are long for humans we're talking
in attains hundreds of thousands of
years so it probably will blow up
sometime in the future you hundred
thousand years
which in in the grand scale of
astronomical timescales is at the blink
of an eye but of course in terms of
human timescales that's quite a long way
to the future quite likely would be
quite dramatic if it did go you'd be
able to see it during the daytime but I
don't think it would cause us any
particular harm could it happen in our
lifetime it could do but then it could
happen anytime in the next hundred
thousand years as well so it's pretty
unlikely at one oh I thought it'd be
cool like a great video if you brilliant
you know if it happens I'll be skating
the phone absolutely
but here's the hole of a selfie matrix
we sort of all the strange shape field
of you just because of the detectors in
this particular camera in the Hubble
Space Telescope so we didn't do been on
that little bit that's before the
supernova blew up so that it's the red
fog we had before
this is the zoom in on the area using
the arrows over love where that
supernovas likely to have been this is
the star which then you are 2012 aw